it seems nobody is immune it's alleged
that angela merkel has been the most
recent victim of nsa spying she's
demanded an explanation from the u.s to
claims that her mobile phone was tapped
despite the gravity of the scandal there
hasn't yet been a comprehensive eu
response there was however a strong
backlash in the european parliament a
majority of meps voted for a resolution
to suspend the eu's swift bank data
exchange agreement with the u.s it's an
outrage that member states governments
have done nothing so far
they are turning a blind eye which is
unacceptable the allegations that the
united states national security agency
has been massively hacking the privacy
of the european citizens should be more
than enough for all of them to tackle
the issue together but this resolution
has been the subject of lively debate
not all meps approved the proposed text
namely members of the epp if we are
lifting this up nobody is looking at the
financial issues of terrorists and this
is for me a security question and
this has nothing to do with all these
what's alleged in the newspaper
regarding swift because we don't have
any proof at all
that
the nsa is really spying on the swift
data whistleblower and former cia
contractor edward snowden exposed this
u.s spying since then allegations have
grown that the nsa has spied on the
private data of many eu citizens this
mep has called for changes to rules on
personal data protection we want to
strengthen the individual rights
especially
transparency and right to information
right to access and also the right to
deletion
and
there we strengthen the idea behind the
right to be forgotten the issue of
personal data protection will likely go
to the negotiating table at the council
summit on friday meps are calling for a
firm response from eu heads of state and
government